loneliness can increase your risk of
heart disease by 29% and Stroke by 32%
which is huge numbers and is not
something to ignore I'm Mia de graph I'm
the deputy editor for health at Business
Insider we're going to talk about how
loneliness affects your brain and
body the thing with loneliness is that
it's quite
complicated when you are lacking in
meaningful social connections your body
is conscious of the fact that you're
alone so it starts to turn up the dial
on your stress response your sympathetic
nervous system starts to go on high
alert so it's natural that you might
feel more paranoid it's natural that you
might feel more suspicious of people and
not feel as open to connecting with
other people and it turns down the dial
in certain parts of your brain where you
feel love connection
relationship then you hit into this
vicious cycle and that's what scientists
refer to as the Paradox of loneliness
because loneliness drives you to retreat
and makes it harder for you to Crave
that meaningful interaction that would
resolve this feeling there's a chain
reaction that happens with the hormones
in your body first thing is your
cortisol levels go into complete
disarray it's what Peaks when you drink
coffee it's also what what wakes you up
in the morning it's that kind of Buzzy
feeling but it's also what elevates when
you get stressed your dopamine increas P
es this is a feel-good hormone but it
really drives you towards quick rewards
so that may be drinking gambling and
going out without thinking about the
consequences for yourself you'll also
see a decrease in serotonin oxytocin and
your natural opioid levels when you
speak to a friend or you eat a meal that
is just so delicious you'll get these
natural rushes of things which will be
natural pain relievers those things will
all decrease
when you're feeling lonely you start to
see this cascading effect on your
physical health so the short-term
effects are an increase in anxiety an
increase in stress so you may Retreat
just generally feel more tired generally
feel less of an Impulse to go out and
also feel this increased anxiety and
paranoia in a lonely body the longer
term effects are you're more likely to
be sick more often more likely to be
susceptible to the flu covid a slight
cough that's going around in your office
that's also linked to pain in your body
so chronic pain back pain or just
generally feeling run down most of the
time your sleep quality is not very good
so you may sleep exactly the same amount
of hours but you'll wake up and you're
quite tired you're slightly uneasy
loneliness impacts your memory that can
lead to cognitive decline it can be a
precursor to dementia increased
inflammation caused by loneliness or
honesty by anything directly impacts the
heart and heart disease is the number
one killer in the US loneliness can even
affect your life expectancy it can
increase your risk of premature death on
a level that's comparable with smoking
which is the number one preventable
cause of death in the US and around the
world it's hard to believe but there is
really strong evidence to suggest that
just connecting with people even if it's
one small piece of the puzle will at
least shift the needle a little bit
towards making you feel better
physically as well as emotionally
there's actually a lot of research that
shows that hearing the voice of someone
you care about has a direct impact on
your brain and on your your nervous
system but there are other things like
art for example art therapy has really
grown in recent years and it's something
that in Sun rehabilitation centers art
therapy is really integral there's a lot
of research that just seeing nature is
really really good for you so going
outside speaking to people picking up
the phone exercising speaking to
strangers ultimately what you're really
looking for is understanding what makes
you happy you're not looking to be
surrounded by people and you're not
looking to engage in a social scene just
to be there what you're looking for is
to connect with people on a level that
really really deeply connects with you
and that will have a really tangible
physical effect act on
[Music]
you